може я тихо ден переговорів і думав вони
справа трубку дорожні карти для тили
німецьких ось так і результат зустрічі у
нормандському форматі у берліні Дева та
прориву про переговори ніхто четвер і
навчи кулів на цівку завалу та експерти
у team впав на важливий і не мати кого у
ряду випробувань спектра this росію-то
краї на масці дно та Європи місто ірлар
результатом це задоволений і козаки
результат часто suite україни archos
правді все-таки буде тіла, але то в нас е
новий шанс чекати на нього було так чудово
шкіряних нових будинків вона стоїть при
полону не вигнута віджимання тисячі через
скільки днів бої спала хован і знову сів
будинків на місці про розвідали син можна
чи буде нова кістки ще убік
доповіді tissues і для тіні
тримайте через конфлікт однак експерти
називають прогресом сам факт зустрічі
на найвищому рівні
он вона дункан завданням було потрібно по
роду символ димарі путіну через ніч
співаєш і не видно син росії з Європи
це США і йому поверни супроводі
навик санте ще до кремля за dieu сирії
в тому до того чиї Росії вигідно і взяти
у нас обидві мавпочкою експерта столиця
скептично про дуже часто рубрику кис
тактичний худим а б показати всю
Росія тут але готова до компромісу в
конструктивних до руки та діалогу
all in hd світло в козу і на тисячу
серце на мене та російський піт хіт чини
вперше повний прогресу в переговорах
визнала яга українська сторона така вас
подарунку самі струмом сларка немечений
ангела меркель створ це фондом а для
чого прогресу might appear міністра
закордонних справ до кінця листопада он
і по ви не затвор дати основу проекту
дорожні карти